Claudia you're working in this latest
film Tulpa with your husband Federico
what's it like being directed by him
that's the second time we work together
but the first time was we did Nairobi
familiar which is a comedy a dark comedy
so this time had we've been through a
real Jala real horror movie and it was
really fun really exciting we we know
each other very well and we're friends
so we shared so much you talked about
this world as being the most challenging
and controversial role you've had in
your life why is that its controversial
because of the it's also we we talk
about sex we talk about sexual
experience but not only in a carnal way
but also in a like mystic way and so
there's a there's so many layers and and
it was a you know challenging because
this world this character is kind of a
double every each of each of us I think
we have a dark side so we are double but
in this case she really lives two
different lives one in the morning in
the office she works for this big
company financial issues very corporate
person and then at night she let herself
go you mentioned there's a lot of sex
scenes in the film on their second
emotion that could be quite difficult as
an actress to get yourself in the right
place for those and may be doubly
difficult because you're being directed
by your husband tell me about how you
got in the right place haha well I I
trust Federico so much so we you know
was easy in a way because we were kind
of
you know joking about it like we break
the eyes at the beginning like okay go
you know like okay I go it's a kind of
unit to take my tip take my shirt off
and being with another guy but and with
my husband next to me but it was very
technical so and I am a very experienced
actress so we just were director and
actress we weren't really bringing up
you know like couple issues I wanted to
ask you a little bit about one of your
next rose when you've just completed
filming on which is labyrinth which is
directed by British director christopher
smith and that's going to be a TV series
isn't it tell me about your role in that
and what we can expect from labyrinth in
labyrinth I am oh my god I'm the villain
in labyrinth I'm a very mean woman I am
it's been it's been a great great
experience we shot this movie in South
Africa Christopher is a great great
director and we have so much fun
marie-cecile has this woman also very
rich very powerful again she's the head
of a big pharmaceutical company but she
wants to be beautiful and young forever
and and she's convinced that with this
the Holy Grail which is a ring and some
Holly bucks she wants this books and the
ring to become to be powerful and live
for taos interview
so she's like she can do anything to get
this she can kill and she does so she's
really really very very she's prepared
to everything she's a very mean woman
and it's very cathartic very liberating
somehow I've never done any bad bad
person you know I've never played any
role like this how much fun was it then
getting really bad getting really
villainous for this role there's so much
fun because I'm a very I'm a very good
person I won't hurt anyone so with his
knife going cutting her throat you know
I was like okay you're a traitor so you
deserve to be killed I was like telling
you it's fine I worked with John Hurt
with many great great actors so it's
been a great experience tell me about
filming in South Africa which is where
you were on location there weren't you
what is it like filming their amazing
this amazing Cape Town is an amazing
city and the nature is except it's
really awesome it's something it's an
experience because I also get the chance
to bring my family so we had chance to
visit around and you know it's a you
really feel like a wide life and it's
beautiful the light is amazing did you
get to do many things off set did you
get to visit the country a little bit
yeah yeah we went to kind of a safari so
yeah yeah I got the chance we were
working 15 hours a day was like well
work work work but I I found a couple of
days off so I found time
I mean I got the chance to experience
something different and that and the
ocean it's really beautiful and did you
know Kate Moss's novel labyrinth before
you're actually offered the role in the
TV series i know i i've heard about that
novo because initially also was really
popular but never read it no then i read
it after so it was a completely
surprised because Christopher told me
that it supposed to be French the
actress but then I don't know how I got
lucky they came in Italy to look for an
actress for Marissa cell so I went to
the audition and I was very happy to get
the road and what else can we look
forward to you from you now my next
movie will be a movie with surgical
stiletto I'm going to do going to film
in September in brown and it's a attack
it's a bittersweet comedy very
interesting it's called the perfect
family we look forward to that thanks so
much to talking to you thank you
you